Wonderful.
Dennis Cagan, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm good. Thank you, Michael.
Wonderful.
Where are you calling from?
I'm in a suburb of Dallas, Texas.
Wonderful.
Okay. I'm actually going to Texas
just in a few days
to see my brother's newborn.
So third time uncle and
I'm very very excited.
What city?
Oh, in San Antonio.
Okay.
So, not too far.
But what I'm very excited to talk to you
in these next 20 minutes or so
is the fact that you've been a part of
I think 67 for profit board of directors,
mostly tech companies.
And I don't think I've met anybody
who was on 67 boards.
So, I'm very excited to talk
in the next 20 minutes
about what it means to be a board member
and what is the role of a board
of a for profit company.
But aside from that, a published author,
an instructor in a business school.
So Dennis, I would love for you
to just give me a really brief intro
to your journey.
How do you get to be on 67 seats
in tech companies?
Well, I started working for IBM in 1967
and I hold some kind of a record.
I worked for IBM for 366 days exactly.
I quit one year to the day
when I started
because I realized that big company
wasn't for me.
But I was already sort of
in the computer industry,
obviously in the '60s.
Then I got a job
selling computer time sharing,
and I realized that the customers
I was trying to sell to didn't know
what to do with a computer.
They liked the idea of time sharing
and remote computing,
but they didn't know what to do.
So, two of my buddies who were engineers
and I, started our first company,
my first company.
And it was a remote access
computing application software company.
And we started it in 1968.
1968 for remote access computing?
That's right. Application software.
That's before the Internet.
Long before the Internet.
And so, and I was an avid reader.
I read the Wall Street Journal,
Business Week, Forbes,
and Fortune, not much else.
So I knew if you had a company
you were supposed to have a board.
So, we had a board.
We created a board.
So, that was my first board.
And then every company I started,
I've started about 18 or founded or co-founded about 18 companies,
mostly tech.
Every single one after that had a board.
So by the time, time passed,
people that I was in business with
knew me as having a board.
So, whenever they thought about a board,
the only person they knew
that was on one was me.
So, I got a lot of questions.
So, that's how I got involved
in one company after another. They said,
"Well, what does a board do?"
And I would talk about it.
And they said,
"Well, would you help me?
Would you be on the board?"
And that's still happening today.
Okay. So, that's how you get introduced
to 67 different board positions.
But when thinking a bit more broadly
about the role of the board of directors,
that's not a controversial topic, right?
I mean, growing up
as a young entrepreneur now,
it's very natural for me
to understand that
Yeah, every group that has
some difficult decision making processes
needs this other group who will oversee it
and sort of strategically think
what is the best way to get
from point A to point B?
Well yes, but you seem to be a step ahead
of most young entrepreneurs.
Most of them recognize,
Well yeah, I have a board,
but me and my partner are fine.
We don't need any other advice
or we don't want
to get anybody involved
because we're afraid.
What if they get control,
and what if we have to listen to them.
And there's a lot of different arguments
and questions.
So they're not as educated as you are.
The primary reason, if you have a company,
you have a board by default, legally.
Right right. In the bylaws. Right.
It may be just you, but you've got one, okay.
Right.
If it's just you, or just insiders,
you're getting the opinion
and the guidance of insiders,
employees and family and whatnot,
you get their guidance anyway.
They're not bringing
anything new to the party.
The reason to have a board
is to expand the perspective
that you're getting to include
highly capable other people
that you respect
who can give you a different perspective,
different experience, different context
than you already possess
to expand your capability.
So, it's like going out
and bringing on some other people
who are highly regarded in their fields
as consultants, so to speak.
Right.
And if you have a private company,
people don't understand.
The CEO reports to the board.
If you're the board,
then you report to yourself, okay?
Right.
But even if you were
the only person inside
or on a seven person board
and you had six other people on the board,
and they all voted against you,
if you own controlling interest,
you just call a meeting and fire 'em,
or you do whatever you want anyway.
If you ... the board reports
to the owners
even though the CEO reports to the board-
So, but Dennis, when I'm thinking about this,
it makes perfect sense.
But there must be some conflict
that sometimes getting a board too early
invested in the company
and too many different ideas
and different perspectives too early
can actually be detrimental
to your progress,
because in my mind,
you're starting a company.
The earlier you are,
the faster you have to move
in order to prove yourself
and to sort of break things, right?
And having more people involved
in the decision making processes
can just make it more difficult.
So, is there a sweet spot
from your perspective on
when it's the right time to have
external people coming in
with their specialty and expertise?
The issue that you're alluding to
is really a factor
of who those people are,
not whether you have 'em or not.
And so, at an early stage,
if you could afford to hire
six of the top people in the country
in certain fields like sales, finance,
marketing, manufacturing,
software development, whatever it is.
If you could afford to hire
six people like that and you would,
then why wouldn't you get
those same types of people,
if not the same people,
to join the board for a few stock options
and get their advice and their input.
Because isn't a board much longer term
that you're saying, you're sort of committing
to have this person a part of your journey
for many years down the line?
Well, that's a good question.
The board is not a lifetime position.
And companies, particularly
in the early stage,
they tend to evolve quickly.
So, the best you might be able to do
is get somebody
who used to be a director of something
at a big company.
But you grow a little
and you gain a little bit more experience
and your company becomes
a little bit more valuable, so to speak,
then you might be able to approach
somebody that has more experience,
is more accomplished.
But what happens to that first person?
You cordially ask them to resign.
You give them their stock options,
and you move on, you cycle through.
Is that common to cycle through
and ask board members to leave?
It's not common enough.
Too many people think
Well, I've committed to them.
I don't want to get rid of them.
Now, one mechanism that most companies use
to avoid that problem
is they have terms.
Like a one year board term,
or a two year board term,
or something like that.
And so, even if
they don't like the person,
they're reticent to ask them to resign
even in a very cordial way.
So they, well, we'll live with this person
even though they're disruptive
and their advise isn't
any good anymore
because in a year and a half,
they'll be off the board anyway.
No, that's wrong.
Make arrangements
for them to leave the board
if they're not doing what you-
That's fascinating. Okay.
I don't think I, in all the board
discussions that I've had around
about the strategy behind
structuring for a board and so on,
very rarely I hear about this, what to do
when you don't have a successful board.
And what I'd love to spend some time on
with you, Dennis, is to get sort of your
to pick your brain on your experiences
and what are some of the most
successful parts of the board
and the least successful parts
of the board experience,
so that I can learn
from your personal experiences.
Well, the best part of a board is that
you receive first class advice
from experienced experts
particularly in areas
that you may not be as competent in,
or you may not have other people
involved in your company
that know a lot about that.
In the early days,
you may not be able to afford a CFO.
So, having an experienced CFO
gives you a financial perspective.
Maybe you can't
Maybe there's nobody in the company
that has big time CEO experience.
So, having a big time CEO
might give you the benefit.
So, you're receiving best of class advice.
Number two, no one person
can think of everything.
And so, by getting together
with a capable group of board members,
men and women and so forth,
then you're likely to get
fresh perspective, innovative ideas,
that you didn't already think
about yourself. Like,
Whoa, I never thought of that.
Particularly board members
are very good in one industry of saying,
"Well in my business,
when we face problems,
we did this and this and this"
And it might not be common
in your business,
but they bring a perspective of things
in other industries,
in other countries, or whatever,
that may have worked well for them.
And it may spark an idea.
It really, it's using the board
as a competitive advantage,
giving you an inside track.
The next thing is, that it can provide
very very impressive optics
for customers, for vendors,
for investors.
I've put people on the board
that people said,
"How did you ever get a person like that
on the board of a startup
that had no revenue?"
I mean, world renowned CEOs
and four star admirals
and all kinds of key.
I got the guy that had been
previously the director of the NSA
to join the board
of a cybersecurity software startup.
So, you don't know who you can get.
I recruited a guy
to one of my boards
a number of years ago,
like 15, 16 years ago,
he's still on the board. He had to retire
because he reached a retirement age.
So, he had been on the board
of General Motors, Raytheon,
Hewlett-Packard, and Hughes electronics
for four years,
and he was previously
the president of Caltech.
And he joined the board of a startup
for some stock options.
And he's still on the board today.
It's not a startup anymore,
but he's still on the board today.
His experience and connections
were invaluable to the company.
And he's just one of a number
of board members over the years.
You don't know who you could get
until you try.
It's an honor to be asked
even if it's not something
that you would consider
for a variety of reasons.
So it gives you, and then
if you're an early stage company,
and you're completely controlled
by insiders,
whether it's a family business
or whether it's a tech startup
and you've got one or two
or three founders,
having independent board members
provides a good buffer
between disagreements.
An independent board member
can mitigate issues between founders,
whether they're family issues,
or founder issues,
and give some perspective.
Like, "Hey Sam. You know,
Bill's got a good point there.
Have you considered this or this"
So that they can soften the kind of conflict
that founders often have.
So, what I'm hearing from this is that
So there's two
really critical lessons there.
One of them is to approach.
Not be afraid, shoot for the stars,
approach the people.
Even if they don't have time,
they'll be honored for asking.
Even if they were
the previous president of Caltech.
And worst case, you'll get a "No.
Talk to me later in a different time"
Right?
The second lesson here is
that you want to make sure
that your board members
are as independent
of a relationship with you as possible,
because they will then
be able to help you go
help mediate through conflicts.
And even if you and your co-founders
are the best coworkers in the world
and you get each other,
conflicts are inevitable.
The decision making will be difficult,
and having somebody independent
will be very useful for those moments
where emotions might kick in
or there's really a vehement disagreement
over something, right?
So, I recruited once the founder,
chairman, and CEO
of one of the five largest tech companies
in the United States to a board
of people he didn't ever know,
in a city that he wasn't in,
but he was interested in their business
so he agreed to join the board.
Now, he was the CEO and chairman
of the company up until the time
it went public originally.
Then he retired.
But on a growing tech company,
that had some similarities to his,
he regretted not staying with the company
after it went public.
It's a very very very famous company.
He left when it went public,
but he never took it from that point
to where it is now.
So he regretted that.
So the opportunity
to join the board of a company
where his input might be beneficial
to get them to the next point
was just a way
that he could participate again
and sort of contribute something.
So, you don't know,
you don't have any idea
the types of people you can get.
Now, it's a chance to interview somebody
even if they don't agree
to join the board. And even if
they don't want to join your board they're,
the likelihood is they're gonna say,
"You know, I can't do it
for these reasons,
but I know somebody else
that might be interested."
And then you get a recommendation
to them from this person.
Right. Definitely.
Okay. So, looking back
at these 67 board positions,
what are some of the key things
or key takeaways that you take
from having a successful
group of board members?
I get why specific individuals
will be great for the company
and for the team.
But at the end, when I think
of a board of a company,
I think of about seven, eight people
sitting around a table
and each of them alone
is a superstar perhaps,
but together, they have to work together
to make some decisions, right.
A lot of the time
there's voting decisions.
So, what makes a successful
group of board members
rather than an individual?
Well as I think you know, in 2012 I thought,
What is it that I know more
about than most people?
I'm a okay CEO, I'm okay at this,
okay at that,
but I'm not the world's best at this.
But what can I claim that I know as much
or more than anybody about?
And it dawned on me, this was in 2012,
that it's private companies
and boards of directors.
And so, that's when I decided
to write my book,
which was published in 2012,
"The Board of Directors
of a Private Enterprise"
And in that book,
there's a chapter, for example,
there's a chapter
on how to fire board members.
As you said, nobody ever talks about it,
but it tells you how and why
to fire board members,
and how to do it successfully.
There's also a chapter about personalities
and things that contribute
to bad boards or good boards.
And that's where you're going now.
So, for example, in there
I have a list of things
that most people never think about
when they recruit a board member.
They think, "Well I need a CEO,
or I need a CFO,
or I need a technology expert,
or I need this or that"
What are some of the things
they never think of?
They never ever say,
Well, I need somebody
that has a great sense of humor.
Or they might think,
Well, I need somebody
that's collaborative.
Or I need somebody
that can park their ego at the door.
- Right.
Or there's personality traits
you're bringing a bunch of type As
to the board, you want to make sure
that they can subjugate their own egos
and listen and focus their energies
for a reasonably limited amount of time
each month or each quarter
on solving the problems of somebody else.
And they need to be able to work together.
If they all have to jump up
on their soapbox and lecture each other.
You can imagine if you got five top CEOs
all in a room, not listening to each other,
but just lecturing each other,
you're not gonna accomplish anything.
So, those people aren't suitable.
And what I tell people is that
they're, depending on what you need
for your board,
you should be filling roles in the board
that are important things for you,
but that you don't feel
are adequately represented
within your employees
and within your other close associates.
What expertise don't they have.
But then I'll tell people
There may be 10 people that are qualified,
maybe 100 people that are qualified
to fill that role in your board,
but there may be only one or two
that are suitable.
Qualified isn't suitable.
What's their personality?
How does it mesh with your culture?
'cause the right board
would be listening, giving their input,
not repeating.
One of my favorite things
that I've learned
from this one guy I mentioned
who had been on all those big boards
is that when the CEO says,
"Okay, well what do you think about this?
What do you think about this?
What do you think about this?"
He goes to each board member.
When it gets to this board member,
if he doesn't have
something different to say,
something that has not been said before,
he'll say, "I agree with what she said"
And that's it.
He doesn't have to get up
on a chair and say,
"Well, I think"
and then repeat
what everybody else has already said.
Is that something very common with boards,
that you end up having ego struggles
rather than solving the actual problem?
Yes, particularly if they haven't been
put together by somebody
that has some experience
or some sensitivity.
That can be very very common.
One time, I had spun a company,
I have another company.
I found a CEO. I set it up.
We moved it to another location.
Later on, that company's now
was bought about two years ago
for about five or $600 million.
But when we brought in
our second round of venture investors,
the first board meeting we had
with the new venture capital investors,
we were standing around in the boardroom
with all the management
and the board members
and the previous investors
that were on the board.
And this guy walked in.
And I was having a conversation
with the CFO at the time.
And this new investor,
venture capital investor,
walked in the room.
And he walked around the room
talking to each group,
shaking their hand,
and very very unusual body language.
So, the CFO turns to me and says,
"What is he doing?"
And I said,
"Oh, don't mind him.
He's just urinating
in all four corners of the room
so that everybody knows
who owns the company now"
Okay. That's not gonna be
a productive board member.
In this case, they had no choice.
He was the lead investor.
However, they also didn't do
their proper diligence
in selecting who was gonna be
that investor to find out, well
who was gonna be on the board.
And I've had CEOs that said,
"Well, I prefer
these two venture capital companies,
'cause they know more about my business"
where I told the CEO, "No.
They have a history of being interfering
and not collaborative.
Even though you think they know more,
I would suggest
these other two venture capitalists,
because they have a history
of being very supportive of founders
and management,
even in tough circumstances"
And the CEO went with his own choice,
and within a year and a half,
they had taken the company away from him.
They had booted him out.
Wow. Okay, Dennis,
I feel like I'm in the middle
of business school here.
This is incredible. And the lesson
that I'm taking from this here is that
at the end, if you're building a company,
it's your baby. You're working so hard
to make it successful.
Sometimes, we get blinded
by the term sheets that we get
or by the names of the ventures.
And we forget to do
the real due diligence,
our due diligence on them,
and understanding
how are they going to ... partner with us
beyond the wiring of the funds
to help us ... burn rate.
How are they going to help us
make the expenses
and to reach our milestones?
And it sounds like really
the most important way to do this is
to actually learn from their experience.
Not ask them how they are on board seats,
but ask other people who they've been
on board seats and get their perspective,
because you can't find this stuff
on Crunchbase,
you can't find it on TechCrunch, right?
This is all internal.
Also, one of the things
that I spend the most time doing
with early stage companies
is preparing their incorporation
and their governance processes
so that investors can't come in
and get control of the company.
There's a number of things
that can be done early on
that can make it difficult for an,
even if an investor gets voting control,
there are things that can be done
earlier on, not at the last minute
but earlier on, that can make it
very difficult for them
to get voting control
beyond just getting 10 votes per share,
or like in Snapchat's case,
no votes for any public shareholders.
There's other more subtle things
that can be done,
but nobody tells the founders
how to do that.
The idea you asked
"When do you bring on a board?"
You definitely bring on a board
before you bring on investors
that are going to want to be on the board.
Right.
You want to form the board
the way it's best for you,
then you want to add
your institutional investors
to that board.
Many people say,
"Well, I'll form a board
and I'll get a stock option plan
as soon as I get investors"
That's too late,
because once you get investors,
they then have a say so
as to who and how many are on your board.
If you do it the way
that you want to do it first
and they join the board,
then they're joining an existing board.
It's a much different dynamic
because the favorite
venture capital board
is two VCs and a founder.
My favorite
venture capital board optimally
is seven board members:
the founder, five or two founders,
five or six outside,
four or five outside ...
and then the venture capital
joins a board like that,
and they don't dominate the company
no matter what their equity.
And you've already set
the expectations and the culture
for the actual board meetings.
- Exactly
So, they're not coming in
and dictating how they want.
Dennis, this was so enjoyable.
Thank you so much again
for your generosity with your time
and the inspiration.
Before we leave, I have to ask you
for three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Well, I think that it comes down to
First of all, at heart,
going back to 1968,
I'm an entrepreneur.
Yeah.
The second thing is that I'm really,
although my major in college
was economics,
I'm really a tech guy.
Starting with IBM and all the way through.
I'm really favorably
inclined towards technology.
All kinds, but mostly IT related.
Semiconductor.
Just a whole bunch of different stuff.
And then lastly, particularly
over the last number of years, governance,
corporate governance,
has really captured most of my interest
and most of my time, including the book.
So it would really be those three things
that would highlight my,
they would be three business words,
not necessarily personal words.
I love it.
Dennis, thank you very very much.
I really appreciate your time and effort.
I look forward to reading the book
as I gear up to start my own company
later on and form my own board members.
So also expect another email
to request some advice from you.
But thank you very very much.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
My pleasure, Michael.
It's the "Board of Directors
of a Private Enterprise"
and it's on Amazon and Barnes and Noble.
Wonderful.
Thank you very much.
Take care.
Thannk you. Take care.